é não é segredo eu sou gremista e cobre
prata e e faz com que a dívida seja
sobretudo escrever com juros
depois vão realizar para é ficção para
internet e televisão
e é nessas horas respondido que eu crio
a mentira que eu escrevo e que depois as
histórias que aconteceram comigo ou com
amigos meus a história que eu conheço da
família e as pessoas não acreditam e
isto é faz faz me pensar é um carinho o
que então torna uma uma história
incrível eu creio que o uso dessa equipe
por powerpoint torna uma história
incrível e primeira coisa que as pessoas
dizem quando não acreditam nessa
história
vou escrevendo tem a ver com isto é que
é extremamente improvável é muito
bizarro é e tem a ver que estão com uma
questão de probabilidade
mas isso não é uma grande pista por uma
coisa extremamente improvável não faz
com que seja impossível
e aqui uma pista que que eu vou tendo
para as pessoas entenderem porque não
acreditam que têm a ver com um choque de
realidade ou seja uma coisa pra mim pode
ser um dado adquirido para outra não é
iraque um caminho onde eu vou dar um
exemplo muito prático e que vocês vão
entender que é pra alguém que tenha um
mínimo de coração ea compaixão por
alguém
não entendo que uma voltagem é uma
infância em toda dos netos é divertir
olhem se vocês não suportam bem e eu não
nos levam ao jardim para vocês verem as
outras crenças a começ lado a lado não
entendem e estão choque de realidades
que vai acontecer aqui eu trouxe algumas
histórias e vamos dizer vou ver a vossa
opinião e vamos ver se acham que é
verdade eo que é mentira está condenada
gosto muito do vosso entusiasmo
então vamos lá ver com estar aqui a
primeira história isso aqui era um
prédio em lisboa e é uma história que
aconteceu comigo então o que acontece é
novo em cima um velho que mora no andar
de cima
comprar um carro elétrico só que assim
como o prédio não tem coragem nem os
prédios ali à volta que eu faço para
carregar o cartão os dias à noite e
aciona o carro à frente do prédio quando
consegue um lugar e depois vem a varanda
e atira para baixo uma extensão elétrica
para ligar à tomada lá acima
só que assim ele é velho velho que é
velha me poupado e então vocês acham que
eu fui medir a extensão do prédio foi de
ir à altura do prédio e foi aqui comprou
uma extensão que o fez foi reuniu as
tomadas todas lá em casa as tripas todas
as escolas do dólar e começou a atirar
pra baixo e até chegar o rachão o
técnico também os presidentes quando
fogem da casa então os nossos cordas
todas lençóis fronhas e naquele tempo
assim mas com carros elétricos
então esta é a visão de levar nanda fica
basicamente um carro o pedrão e há
pessoas que tiveram sorte de calhar com
uma ficha tripla altura da varanda para
isso aqui é uma oportunidade de ter uma
oportunidade poupança para toda a gente
ficaria com uma coisa destas
àquela altura pronto é o que eu sou a e
como é que isto por uniões condomínio
vizinho que vão falando entre a toda a
gente aproveitar aquela cidade para
alertar os gestores cabelo dinheiros
sujos que não pagam conta nenhuma
pessoas que colocam as máquinas de lavar
roupa e lavar louça é trabalhar e as
pessoas também já terão estas máquinas
nos quartos que estarei mais perto das
chamadas é que da varanda seguinte às
vezes no vizinho não consegue lugar a
porta nec é bastante freqüente então tem
que estacionar o carro do outro lado da
rua e então a corda
eu faço máxima barriga né atravessar o
prédio todo o que dificulta e muito usar
estas tomadas mas também não é problema
porque uma pessoa faz uma puxada e puxa
aquilo volta para para nós para dentro
do prédio pra ficar a uma altura a uma
altura que seja decente
bom essa história é uma mentira é
mentira isso é completamente vedada e
teve nezinho que eu tenho né na varanda
e que honestamente só para carregar as
coisas básicas porque se também um carro
alto velho que eles vejam isto eu disse
que produz consultou a marca dos caras
que vão dizendo que um casamento fica a
volta de um euro
só que eles que fez as contas e eu não
entendo e não sabido desconfia que
alguém estava mais no não confronta e
que fez as contas demandas trazidas é
nova tensão que teve que pedir a edp é
tudo junto mas quando elas irá aparecer
assim o que eu digo que é um preço caro
alto para salvar o planeta mas não faz o
povo está claramente do lado a próxima
história te ver com estes senhores
jovens empreendedores que criaram um
produto fascinante que são estes boxers
azuis que protegem as nossas partes
baixas da radiação dos telemóveis está
um produto é que existe e ao cinema mas
vamos apresentar esta é uma feira de
tecnologia
vamos mostrar então vamos lá nos boxes
para mostrar o produto está um cabo frio
e então vieram também os meias de vidro
e políticos têm aquelas pernas em forma
de boneco de cera e alta tecnologia para
proteger as partes baixas
isso aqui é provavelmente dirá isso é
completamente verdade e é um produto que
existe mas parta custa 50 dólares cada
para boxers e é e são coisas que existem
não quero estar aqui né
você pode usar um trauma uma mesma hora
na mochila foi deixada no no prédio da
minha avó e minha carteira por favor não
tocar a campainha
os doentes a descansar a janela do
terceiro andar está aberta eu tinha uma
presença nas quartas se faz favor
eu adoro isso porque fica sempre a
imaginar o carteiro é olhar a medir a
força que é preciso ter se tiram a carta
vai voar para o outro lado da rua
os quatro quadrilhas dentro e em volta a
ter peso né
a obra uma carta da edp em forma de
avião para tirar e isso é verdade é
mentira é completamente mentira eu fizer
preta e coloquei o corpo lá no prédio da
minha avó e avô me perguntou ela viu
isto é não não serei eu e julieta a
dizer que há pessoas muito doentes não
gostaram da área só que sob o comando do
3º andar mais para ela arranja se sempre
bom
essa história de uma senhora que não
entendeu a letra do médico numa receita
e é que eu vou colocar creme para a
direção nos olhos novamente irá
completamente de lado e sei o que eu num
mau médico e ele confundiu não visitar
os convites apostas é realmente chato é
é bastante possível e ela disse que mal
colocou os olhos fecharam encerraram
muito ela começou a chorar e que chamava
chamar uma ambulância para irem salvar
alguma coisa estava de lado estava na
próxima história está uma carta escrita
por uma senhora este é o meu trabalho na
escola professor larissa deram esta
carta é uma mãe queixar-se da professora
do filho dela que trabalha nesta escola
que a postura deu como não há problema
vamos analisar esta carta o time voltar
a ser professora isabel eu sou mãe há 11
anos e nunca vi uma pessoa tão
irresponsável sem coração e inimiga dos
seus próprios alunos daquelas pessoas
que dizem que no trabalho não para fazer
amigos vai mais fazer inimigos
ainda por cima com crianças de 11 anos
acho um caso exagerada e vela no último
teste tudo maio o meu filho roberto teve
não satisfaz uma pessoa ficava um caso
em nada né
como é que em pleno século 21 e ainda
crianças que chamam roberto oitavas esta
criança né
mas continua se eu não sabia bater e é
porque alguém não lhe ensinou
escusava também dar respostas todas
numeradas injusto se o meu filho acha
que um carro nasci de novo quando é que
é o problema e fala que o problema não é
se ela achasse que um cão nasce de um
ovo kinder aí eu já vi que há um papel
para levar assim a ciência ainda hoje
não tem resposta para tudo e às vezes
mamíferos são capazes de efeitos
surpreendentes e que sentimos que ela
sabe qualquer coisa né vai partilhar
connosco ciência surpreendente avó em
1922 para salvar um gatinho é órfã
também deu de mamar da própria ana e
todos os veterinários diziam para parar
com aquilo mas é verdade que o barco
salvou-se e viveu durante muitos anos
gta fotos dela saltar recorrer por favor
este animais e tenha humildade e
trabalhar a mente e eu fiquei curioso se
existem estas fotografias
eu vou à internet procurar 1922 é
daquelas fotografias crianças estavam
quietas muito parada sem costuras
responderam cinco minutos e um gato em
princípio há sempre os autos pois esta
segunda feira não sei se vão existir mas
também por outro lado o rating está a
mamar para estas fotografias e fui
procurar e não havia mais abrir um novo
mundo que é esta coisa desarmar e gatos
está um fenômeno e há muita coisa na
internet
por isto temos uma senhora generosa é a
área não era um gato que já escreve
médium atuam eo lugar todo satisfeito
messi se acham que esta senhora é
generosa a pessoas mais nervosas que
conseguem com dois gatos
o tigres é dar de mamar e aquelas mães
que acham que o senhor se de um caso dos
mamilos branca manteve a amamentação
esta senhora são dois tiros
não há nada a dizer sobre isto e vocês
nem podem na festa as fotografias e
achar mas estes são casos muito
específicos pessoas que não foram mais e
têm muito amor pra área e sentem que têm
o instinto maternal à flor da pele
querem partilhar e gatos foram que
encontraram não totalmente mentira
porque as pessoas conseguem partilhar em
crianças têm filhos bebés têm tudo
imagens de crianças continua a carta
se não voltar a cruzar o teste e não der
vou a nota o roberto vou falar com a
televisão ou pior
faço um posto no facebook explicar tudo
com muitas partidas
ele quis realmente 3 abreu e da
arrogância dela que acha que vai fazer
um post revela ter logo humilhar
partilhas e life para fazer um posto né
vai falar com visão e olha que foi
falado e esta carta que o autorizam
rapidamente e foi abrir o telejornal e
vou fazer um pequeno uma discussão entre
maragatos não há provas que vão pra
projeto para a criança e houve uma
pequena discussão com esta carta quase
nenhum prós e contras né
essa carta é verdade é mentira essa
história é completamente mentira
esta carta nem escreve uma carta
qualquer conteúdo da internet
isto é que estava ter visto no prós e
contras é o pai pronunciar se uma
criança é afinada mas não é testado até
ter nesta escola
bom é é uma conclusão que o seguinte na
maioria dos casos a nossa vida é
bastante monótono é casa trabalho
trabalho casa e obviamente fazer uma
sopa para o resto da semana é isso uma
monotonia tremenda e por isso que a
ficção
e dani tem tantos tantos s é um papel
tão importante um papel tão importante
na nossa vida e por isso que a maioria
das vezes nós nem sequer nos preocupamos
em perceber sua história é real ou se é
mentira
e é por isso também que nós continuamos
a contar ao longo de gerações histórias
de vampiros lobisomens e quando nós
temos a ver por exemplo star wars
ninguém está preocupado em perceber se
os abalos são verdadeiros ou não
consegue resistir à ficção científica
tem previsto é a realidade ea realidade
vai continuar a mostrar se com a
infecção diz tudo hoje em dia acredito
em tudo
acreditam em femininos acreditam que uma
só pergunta virá acreditam até que terra
é plana
esta malta né como criador de conteúdos
é e minha vida é o objetivo será sempre
criar alguma surpresa algum entusiasmo
algum algum ganso nas histórias que eu
vou criando e nessa luta essa luta é uma
luta diária é a realidade das favelas de
facto uma tremenda seca eo varejo
público também a questionar se ea um
exercício diário que tentámos perceber a
nós queremos uma realidade irreversível
fazer sopa ou eventualmente também estão
interessados numa versão ao que fixe
nada mas que nos entusiasmo e como nós
vimos com esses temos com o que nos
trouxe a este estupidez humana real tem
muitas mesmo muitas ficções procurar
obrigado
[Aplausos]